according to palacios realty this is one
of the best moments in history to buy
and sell homes
rocky spoke to one of their realtors to
learn more
hey jerry welcome to las vegas now hey
rocky thank you so much for having me
of course of course we're talking
palacios realty i know you have
a lot of advice to give us so let's
start with the first question here is
now
a good time to sell your home
uh there's no uh number of ways i could
say
yes absolutely so many times
please it is absolutely the best time to
sell
uh 2020 took its toll right but at the
end of the result for us as realtors
at the moment here in january we have
one month of inventory of single family
homes here in las vegas
if we were to put everything together
condos town homes uh land
uh we're looking at 1.8 months worth of
inventory
to give you a perspective there a normal
healthy market should be around six
months
so we've got a lot of work in front of
us and what that currently means is that
for sellers
uh we're literally experiencing the
ultimate seller's market right now it's
just never been a better time to sell
and buy actually because of course rates
are phenomenal right in fact if you
if you put it on the market today you
price it right you should be seeing
activity and probably in contract within
14 days
it's kind of unprecedented but yes one
of the bright spots of the time right
that's
good and now if i've ever if i've never
bought a home like myself for example
what are the steps involved in that
process
there's literally two things that you
should do if you're thinking about
buying
and the first one ironically is to meet
with a realtor
and the reason is is because you want to
be able to
walk through a consultation where you've
got all of your dreams
all of your ideas and it just allows you
to kind of put it out there
and a good realtor will be able to work
through that consultation and help
develop an ideal strategy for you
and put a timeline to it that just works
for you and your family
and now the second and equal component
to that is of course
apply with a mortgage lender to find out
exactly how much you can afford
well yeah i get to check off the first
one there for myself right now
right now about this okay and can i
actually get a
get a home uh with a zero down payment
so the zero down payment is uh
as is absolutely yes possible we've had
multiple clients
do this successfully now in order to get
the best results
it certainly matters who you work with
uh and of course being able to have the
right lender
with the right program and a strong
negotiation uh a
strong negotiator as an agent be able to
help you get the right terms
all of those things play a role in
helping you achieve that zero down
payment
option it is possible in today's market
the state of nevada
offers down payment assistance programs
several of them
uh and so if you pick the right lender
and you have the right program that
works for you in your situation
you can absolutely get to that point
where you walk into a house
with almost nothing out of pocket so it
just really matters we do your homework
do your research and of course
if you need more information you can
always reach out nah shameless plug call
flossie as you can see
well here's another one give palacios
realty a call 702-333-6666 and
they have a special offer right now call
them and mention channel 8
for a free one-year home warranty with
home purchase
we'll be right back